you want an Oscar for your performance
in Dallas Buyers Club
can you tell the story of becoming that
character Ron Woodruff
what was the toughest part
the toughest part
which was the most enlightening part
was good to know who he was in between
the lines we're based on a life story in
an hour and a half of film
and script is great
but who was he in between
the lines who was he before
he started a business before he was on a
crusade
before he went to alternative medicines
and
you know the the the obvious thing
people always talk about well how did
you lose all that weight that was not
hard that was just to
militaristic decision
this is what I can eat each day and if I
do this
each day for a week I'll lose 2.5 pounds
in a week so I'm gonna give myself five
months to do that 2.5
times as 10 there's go there's 47 pounds
that was like clockwork so that was easy
that decision was made
I didn't go to the Pizza Hut buffet and
have Temptation in front of me had
certain meals I ate that when the weight
just went off like clockwork
it was the who is
Ron Woodruff in between the lines and
what the gift I got given that gave me
the insight to who that man was
his I went to see his family
and his uh
before I was as I was leaving
his family offered me his diary
and I remember it kind of has it going
wow yes but I kind of hesitated because
it felt
maybe a little too intimate of a thing
for
me to have I felt like it was kind of
maybe infringing a bit but I
opened my hand and took it and what I
got in the diary was I've got to know
who Ron was
before he had HIV
and little thing the dire he'd write in
and in the the the the the dreamer he
was and the getting all set on a Sunday
night and laying his shirt out and
ironing it for the next morning making
sure there's a little pager had fresh
batteries in it because tomorrow morning
he was going across town to hook up some
speakers
for 38 bucks or whatever
and then getting up that morning and
writing about what kind of coffee he
drank and how much gas it was going to
take to get over a Crosstown to do that
job and hook up those beakers and then
on the way over
page coming in to say no we don't need
you we've gone with somebody else to
hook them up
and here he was all buttoned up two cups
of coffee in
hair slicked over
shirt ironed
[Music]
a little less than half a tank of gas
but enough to get back home
Now where's this Monday go
The Hope and the disappointment you have
to take all that in that's part of that
man I'm gonna I'm just gonna go to Sonic
and get
double cheese bacon burger because
Sheila over there man she's kind of cute
she always gives me half price on it
yeah
which leads to
rolling the joint
hanging off till Sheila gets off to work
sneaking over to the local motel and
shagging up at room 16. that's my lucky
number 16. she laughed
then wandering out that night
getting home one in the morning
no plans for Tuesday
and maybe later in the week think about
what am I going to do about work or job
and these little dreams would get me
Peak and want to and then something
would happen where he wouldn't follow
through or the deal would go down the
deal would go south
that no one who that that there's in
there was where I saw who
he was a dreamer
and and and he just couldn't catch the
break and didn't follow through and then
I remembered his family he said like oh
yeah he invented he got patents on a
whole bunch of things but he never would
he had things to get patented but never
would follow through to get the
government patent and then later on
you'd see the product
be made or sold on QVC or something
they'd be like Ron that was yours
or they still your idea did you patent
that he'd be like
like never would that there's something
beautiful and sad about that yeah yeah
that let me inside who he was
in his heart and um who he wanted to be
and we was hoping to be in trying to be
couldn't quite
pull off when you go that deep this
there's a part of him stay in you
forever
are you able to let go I I mean I hope
so I get I look there's a tenacity
to to to survive that I got
from him look hopefully I can try and
find some of that in different ways
in any character that'll go play because
that's if you if you
if you really want to give a character
an obstacle to overcome a need
I mean the base one is life and death
whether that's
the need to survive or the need to Stave
off Extinction
I'm not talking about what the rules the
laws are the social mores the manners
and Graces I'm fighting you're gonna
fight for your own life in a world
that's not supporting you to do so
you there's a wonderful courage of
[__] it
watch this
what do I got to lose
my life
or I'm in charge
of extending it get out of the way
and I'll pick your pocket along whatever
it takes
so there's a tenacity to live by
whatever means necessary to survive that
I that I that I'm reminded
of
that I learned from raw